I see yes why that's a little difficult
to explain I've got all night
hey youtubers it's Charlie so we finally
got to see the first episode of Sherlock
series 3 the empty hearse
we all had a bunch of questions so I
asked you to post them in the comments I
still have to watch the episode a couple
more times before I do my breakdowns
there's just so much stuff so I'll
probably post that on Friday I'm also
working on a Peter Capaldi video to be
sure to subscribe to get them since I
have to reference a lot of specific
events during the episode just consider
this a broad spoiler warning just like
last time I picked 20 of your questions
so let's get started number one laughs
of thunder asks Sherlock seem much more
human did something happen while he was
away to cost this change and will they
address it in the next two episodes yes
something did change he got super lonely
if you remember when he and Mycroft are
doing the deductions game he puts the
Hat on he was actually you know making
fun of Mycroft for being lonely but when
he puts that hat on the lonely man hat
we'll just call it the lonely man hat he
basically is talking about himself being
lonely he really miss Watson and they
kind of addressed that during the course
of that first episode episode 2 will
deal mostly with the Three's Company
situation that's going on with Mary
Morstan question number 2 Chaz Madison
asks what was Anderson's involvement
with the Jack the Ripper book so that
was actually just Anderson's fan club
the empty hearse trying to pay homage to
Sherlock they know he likes puzzles so
they were trying to impress him
obviously it didn't turn out very well
but it'd be like you doing a video of
yourself reenacting Sherlock scenes and
setting it to Benedict Cumberbatch you
know trying to impress him with your
acting skills that's basically what they
were doing question number three yang Zi
Han asks what was up with the scene with
Sherlock and Moriarty so yeah that was
kind of intense if you weren't prepared
for it they were showing us you know
what all the possible theories were they
weren't meant to be real theories you
know they were just meant to be
possibilities so that was just Mark
Gatiss paying homage to that question
number four the chief Gaming asks I
thought they should have given us the
final Sherlock live solution at the end
so yeah a lot of people had this
question where they said you know how
come they didn't explain explicitly what
the actual solution was if you remember
that scene where Sherlock tells Anderson
you know everyone's a critic
that's just Mark Gatiss saying that you
know no matter what the actual solution
is fans would never be happy so they're
not even gonna try and tell us what it
is this wasn't worth at 13 possibilities
comment comes in where they're basically
just saying that the fans
have probably come up with scenarios
that are more complex and interesting
than the writers ever could question
number five fangirl 1502 asks do you
think Molly's boyfriend will be
important later so yeah a lot of Molly's
boyfriend questions I don't think that
he's at a part it's a bit tricky because
obviously you know Maury already turned
out to be the main villain the last time
there was a lot of aspects of this
episode that mirrored other episodes of
Sherlock but I don't think that they
would do something quite so obvious it
was just meant to be a funny scene and I
think the real joke is is that he looks
exactly like Sherlock and it was just
meant to be funny question number six
ivy hey asks what was up with Sherlock
in the tunnel when he was with Molly and
Greg and is Molly still in love with
Sherlock so more Molly questions there's
a lot of money questions that I got so
no she's not still in love with Sherlock
she'll always have a soft spot for him
but that scene were they part ways is
just meant to show that she's moving on
with her life and the mine palace scene
the scene where you know he's going all
weird in his head it's basically just a
new way that they're visualizing the
mind Palace on-screen question number
seven Suraiya mulchand asks is Donovan
coming back realistically I think that
that scene at the beginning where they
referenced her and Anderson discrediting
Sherlock is probably the most will ever
see of her question number eight by team
at Hudson asks was the tube a reference
to V for Vendetta good question so it's
similar it was actually a reference to
the original event the Gunpowder Plot of
1605 that was what V for Vendetta was
based on so it's based on the actual
event the Guy Fawkes event question
number nine lady loves music one asks
what do you think about the theories
that Mary dies in episode three in the
original novels Mary actually dies after
she marries Watson and in between two
books she doesn't even died during a
story it's like the empty house the
episode that this is you know loosely
based on I don't know how true to the
texts that are going to be but you know
Mark Gatiss and Steven Moffat are very
good about including references but they
do take a lot of liberties I'd be very
disappointed if it was exactly the way
it happens in the books I don't think
that's gonna be the case but the villain
this season has already said Watson on
fire she's already taken that next step
that Moriarty never did question number
10 me tamashii guests why did Cheryl I
go to Anderson and explain how he fell
off the building the reason he explained
that story to him it's a false story by
the way it's not the real story which is
because he was playing with him a little
bit he knows about his empty hearse fan
club question number 11 / Angela
sigh asks is Mary going to be
compromised by the villain I think she's
going to be part of the plot I don't
think that she's going to be involved
with the villain I don't think she's an
evil person question number 12
summer Bradshaw asks what happened to
Sally Donovan so she's still part of the
force she's just not part of the season
3 narrative yet like I said earlier
she's not listed in the credits so we
won't know until we actually see episode
2 or 3 question number 13 Matt Dawson
asks who does Sherlock keep speaking to
when he's talking to himself he was just
hallucinating Watson he was just you
know remembering things the way they
used to be whenever he was with Molly
question number 14
Philip ro Kovac asks which theory is the
closest to being correct so you know I
did a Sherlock lives video so I think
that my theory is the closest obviously
he kind of let slip when he's talking to
Mary that he didn't fall off the
building but that doesn't mean that he
didn't jump off so I'm sticking with my
own theory but honestly all the theories
they showed have elements of truth so if
you combine all those I think that
you'll find what actually ended up
happening number 15 Blake Hutton asks
what do you think about the way we met
his parents I didn't really think it was
necessary though they didn't really feel
like they were part of the narrative
other than to be a joke for his family
and obviously they paid off that lady's
moment with Mycroft later and that was
funny but I didn't think the story
needed it question number 16 Donna Bella
asks what was your favorite theory that
they showed us I didn't have a favorite
theory but I did think the funniest one
was the Moriarty Sherlock one that was a
little bit ridiculous it was a bit of a
WTF moment I just lost my screen and
went no no no no no you know so you get
the idea question number 17
Charlie Melville asks how many moustache
jokes were there hey your name like my
name there were definitely at least ten
I'll try to have an exact number for my
breakdown but what happened is they all
came in spurts so someone will make a
moustache jokes and then it'd be like
knocking a domino over there'd be like
three more moustache jokes and then
there'd go you know awhile without any
jokes and then someone else would make
another joke and there'll be like three
more moustache jokes so they were all
concentrated in like little groups
question number 18
Alison Lee asks do you think it will
turn out that Mary is working with the
villain she solved that code pretty fast
so like I said earlier no I don't think
she's you know literally involved with
the villain I think she'll be part of
you know whatever that final plot is in
the final episode whenever Sherlock was
analyzing her it made it seem like she
was a bit foolish
she's kind of like a less silly version
of Molly question number 19
X crystal X 101 xx asks when Sherlock
was scanning Mary the word liar popped
up what do you think this means I
actually just think that it means that
she's lying about her past till Watson I
think you know she's probably trying to
conceal something like a previous
marriage or you know something that
happened in her past I don't think that
she's you know trying to lie about her
involvement with the villain or anything
like that question number 20 Tom Monty
asks who's your favorite Sherlock
character of all time
not including Sherlock so I would say
that my favorite character is Molly
Hooper you know she's the funniest she's
the warmest she's the most sincere I
really hope of all the characters that I
hope gets a happy ending I hope that
it's Molly so thank you so much for
submitting all your questions everyone
I'll be doing a breakdown video tomorrow
and then episode 2 is gonna air on
Sunday and it'll be the same drill I'll
do a non-spoilery review and then a Q&A
video after that be sure to subscribe to
get all those videos I'm also working on
that Peter Capaldi video for Friday - my
predictions for series 8 right now you
can click here to watch my episode 1
review and you can click here to get
that breakdown all add the annotation as
soon as I post the video thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you